and he was like oh
god yes
that's what he said oh don't break my
heart god yes
sometimes i get so lonely
[Music]
guys what's going on what's good people
happy monday fun day thank you for
joining us today
uh we're super happy to have you
my as promised i did get my hair cut i
did get my haircut you guys did
yeah this way he's capped up
um
but yeah obviously guys you really know
what to do i'm gonna fly through it last
couple episodes i've spent like 10
minutes going for the intro i'm not
gonna muck around today guys pause the
thing right now real quick pause the
thing head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs join us
over there guys join us please embrace
the cult you're missing out missing out
white robes and yeezys is the uniform
and everyone around there is chirps and
tings and clapping cheeks all day and
having laughs guys every day and on top
of that they get a bonus episode every
thursday
they've got two and a half years worth
of content to binge through on patreon
so guys head on over there as soon as
possible and uh enjoy yourself live
lavish with us in the uh the sng cult
if you're watching us on youtube please
guys like the video if you liked the
video
subscribe to the channel we're flying
through now i think we're like
126 27 000
subs oh god yeah
yeah yeah getting through it sub 130k
songs
um youtube now i don't know youtube no
yeah they keep track we don't bother
about it that's all numbers here we're
just here for the fun i saw that numbers
chat yeah um but always guys
like subscribe ring that notification
bell so you know when we're posting and
there's always chirps of thing in the
comments guys
we need the breeding grounds for the log
cabin we need the cult to grow and grow
we want to take over a small town
uh and just live like mormons i was
literally just living
and always guys if you're listening on
spotify apple podcast wherever you
listen to your podcast please leave us a
nice review listen all the way through
and tell a friend to tell a friend and
without any further ado
my homie my main man
my sighting
fire lord forex is going to hit you with
something
oh my goodness
oh
my deep throat danger buddy oh my lord
foreign facts
let's go come on sugar yes yes with the
facts and the knowledge please hurry
all right bet so you know we're
skydiving soon right so jay sent me this
fun fact i don't know if he sent it to
you but he said it to me is it gonna put
me off
we'll see it's a video
and i'll explain the question i'll show
you the video in a second so basically
a woman was skydiving and i think
her parachutes or whatever didn't deploy
on time or didn't deploy safely and she
landed but she landed
on like a bed of
like an ant hill farm
site stupid like that so she was covered
in like red like bites and stuff but
from the from landing on that on that um
anthill she got so many biases sent her
it gave her so much adrenaline that
that's what kept her alive wow
until the hospital
what's the odds of that
it's called i think she the title of it
is called the luckiest
the luckiest unluckiest dive or
something like that i've never heard of
the luckiest and the unluckiest sky that
yes
ever yes this lady her name is joan
murray she was like 46. she was on her
like 36th solo dive right and she jumps
out of the plane and like 45 seconds in
she um she pulls her ripcord to let the
pressure down it doesn't like deploy so
she pulls her reserve where it sends her
into us like into a death spiral right
everybody's watching like oh my god
she's gonna die like she's she's falling
way too fast so she makes it to the
ground and plummets plummets the earth
and she [ __ ] breaks like every bone
in her body and the ambulance they rush
her to the hospital and they cannot
believe that she's alive they notice all
these like red like these dots on her
like a crazy rash all over all over her
and they find out that she landed on a
fire ants nest which uh got her
respiratory system going and gave her
enough adrenaline to keep her heart
going until she got to the hospital have
you guys ever heard of the the luckiest
nah
bro bro that's one in a gazillion
literally that is never gonna happen
again to anyone nah especially not
you especially not you [ __ ] hell yeah
definitely what happened to me for sure
you'll just land and die oh fam
i couldn't pull one and let not deploy
and then pull another and then spiral i
don't i don't i'm letting go of the
whole thing because i'm dying regardless
i don't want to die disoriented do you
know what i mean you're gonna die dizzy
yeah yeah yeah i'm just nbc was coming
taking off the whole backpack rags let
me just fall and plummet yeah like
what's like my man from
was it civil war
um
uh the blackbird i can't remember his
actual name um iron man's number two
that's also got a suit oh the war
machine he plummets and hits the floor
that's how i'm gonna hit the floor i'm
not gonna i can't i can't be dealing
yeah
[Applause]
my god yeah bro that's um
nuts
i couldn't be just floating down and see
that happen to you
that'll be wild nah
it ruined the whole experience of course
i know i just like
so you're so selfish
did you watch the safety video or not
yo uh that ghost shot could never ever
do a solo dive thing yeah i don't know
why anyone would want to do it did i my
mom would have to be paused strapped on
me yeah you have to be car i couldn't i
couldn't
[ __ ] yeah that's intense man that's way
too intense bro jesus christ but yeah
that's the fun fact of the day guys fair
play right
let me hit us early with a uh and am i
the [ __ ] oh interesting
i think this one's juicy you know
wow starts off i've got a juicy am i the
[ __ ] for it
maybe it's not juicy maybe she just
swindled me into it
right okay cool
ah right
a bit oh wait i do remember this one it
is juicy okay it's juicy
i've been best friends with this girl
um
since i was three to four years old
we're both 24 years old now
she started seeing this guy brackets no
idea how they met
and from the start he was stressed about
money and financial difficulties i
encouraged her to take things slow with
him but did this [ __ ] listen no chance
a month or two later they're in a
relationship and she's sending him 500 a
month
and trading for him i don't know what
that means
like stop trading and stuff i get i
thought that might be it but it seems it
seems like a wild thing that's the only
thing i can think of is the only thing i
could think of as well when she said it
but i think that if man needs 500 a
month what are you doing on the stock
market what are you doing on the stock
market you ain't got money to be trading
nothing what do you mean
what's he trading
i don't know why
he's trading you know
[ __ ] knows right
[Laughter]
all right and trading for him yeah he
doesn't live in london but she would pay
for train tickets for him to come uh to
come and see her and pay to stay in a
hotel
she would pay for his clothes and
trainers because she's in love what the
[ __ ] i have told her countless times he
is using her and to test it by stop
paying for his things but she said she
can't because she will lose him
[Laughter]
oh my god fam
they have now been together for just
over a year
he has posted his exes on his stories
saying he misses them
he has countless times told his
girlfriend that he's [ __ ] hella
[ __ ] on nights out
once again i have screamed to her he is
a lying conniving cheat
but she remains blind to the fact he
clearly gives no [ __ ] about her
she has told me he only does missionary
won't eat her out and it said he is did
dead a given head
do i need to say any more about this man
however
he gets really angry and protective if
she has male friends and will block her
for days when he's angry
he will come back when he needs money
shock
[ __ ] shock she truly believes he
loves her because his boys know about
her
bro
is it finished are you done okay
am i the [ __ ] for wanting to cut this
girl out of my life
uh seeing after have
what seeing as half that i have i think
that's what's trying to say seeing
as
after
have been friends for seeing we've been
friends for 20 seeing as we've i'll just
read it how it should be ready yeah
seeing as we've been friends for 20
years or so but is emotionally draining
to listen
uh to listen to absolute lack of
self-respect this girl has for herself
i've told her
countless times to leave him so recap
guys
there is uh so two friends they've been
friends for over 20 years
girl a finds herself a new man
he's broke yeah she gives him at least
five bills a month
and looks at the markets and he's on
she's on the stock market for him yeah
she's [ __ ] she's up at seven hitting up
these u.s trains
um he doesn't live in london so when he
wants to come and visit her she has to
pay for his travel and book him a hotel
to stay in that doesn't make any make
sense no sense why don't you stay at the
yard i'm at you know what i mean
[ __ ] knows he's getting a teddy bear
because he wants to bring his next thing
down yeah yeah he wants to double up
when he's in london but yeah continue so
he has no money yeah he takes money from
her she pays for his travel she pays um
for his his places to stay
um takes money from her every month um
when he's pissed off he'll just block
her
and when he's broke he'll come back on
block
her justificat when he gets vex um or
when he he
he posts pictures of his ex-girlfriend
his stories and says i missed that
i missed that
and uh yeah when he's vexed with a
hillblocker for days
uh and the justification she has for the
fact that he loves her is that his boys
know that she exists
so homegirl
friend number two says i can't
bear to listen to this [ __ ] anymore i
don't even want to be our friend anymore
if i have to continue to listen this i
can't be boys of her
is she the [ __ ] first and foremost i
like to say city boys are one up now
we've got we've finally got a point
finishing we finally finessed it because
a week and a half ago when these men
were paying 15 months rent and expenses
i don't think you might understand how
angry i was oh we saw it i was living we
saw it so city boys we got one back
safer
[ __ ] safer
run up run him that five bills and run
him that stock trade as well yeah
yeah i was so angry um
inexpensive 15 months and rent
wow i could i could have oh god i
couldn't i was so funny james but yeah
no she's not the ass off for wanting to
lock off her friend for her friend being
so stupid about her current relationship
oh if it was you i'd lock you off sir
i'd warn you family
and thrice
you'll give me one stern warning you're
like a fu hat this can't happen again
it's me or her
i'm not listening to this again
i'm not [ __ ] listening to james i'm
in love
james i love this girl and she loves me
how the [ __ ] does she love how the [ __ ]
does she love you bro all her girls know
about me all that girls know about i
promise you would fight
i would leap across this fridge
scattering all the while hydrates
i will scout all the bottles and i come
for your throat fam
[Laughter]
i'm actually sure your um is dumb your
friend is just dumb like she has to be
buttered darm and in love like it just
doesn't make sense because
she clearly doesn't know what real love
is she doesn't know what a good home
feels like someone that looks after you
and takes care of you big man
you're buying a hotel for this brother
to come down
when he can't even he's not staying in
your yard why is he staying in a hotel
fam
i'ma tell you why because he's jamaican
he lives in nottingham
and he wears burberry and burberry only
only he's definitely jamaican doesn't
heow he's definitely jamaican he's
definitely jamaican
dead
asking the jamaican to eat out is a it's
a declaration of war
cardinal sin no banksy but it's a
cardinal sick yeah yeah
it's not happening it's not [ __ ]
happening it's jamaican
burpee and perfect only
that's too funny
he tries to pattern multiple yachts in
this this london thing
and this there the main girlfriend here
is a full
what do you say 500 a week a month it
could never be five a week who can
afford it i was just trying to wrap my
head around it 500 a month regardless
though like how much are you making to
afford to be able to pay 500 a month and
a hotel every time he comes down she
can't afford it like what she's in love
she just can't afford it what's she
doing man well i used to work with
abreya
who um i actually think he listens to
this show but he needs to hear it oh
yeah are you so good at prayer to be
fair i've told him bear time
with him we asked in the office we used
to slow him for this okay he was a user
and abuser of his girlfriend no he
wasn't bro so this is when we worked in
sales right okay
so
if you missed commission
if you hit your commission in this job
you were living lavish if you missed
commission they wanted you to feel it oh
really you'd have to live off like 1200
pounds for the month
oh the basic there was cheap it was like
16 1700. okay um no 16 17 grand a year
was the basic
commission was fat but um
i think i missed my commission once i
was struggling you felt it basically i
was struggling
i couldn't for petrol to and from work
it was wild anyway
i seen this guy miscommissioned like
five or six times and every single time
he would miss commission
he would be online shopping because he
used to do airsoft you know airsofters
nah it's like paintballing okay but with
like these little pellets okay people
take it [ __ ] seriously okay
it's like extreme paintball basically
it's just it's just long
anyway he was obsessed with it cool he'd
spend hundreds of pounds on this stuff
hundreds of pounds he'd spend spent
spend when he had no money and then just
get the rest from his girlfriend when he
needed to eat and pay rent you get it
from his girlfriend no way bro and he
never used to bang his misses
no way yeah by user banger he didn't
find her attractive
so bro i remember he told a story one
time they went out to like a wedding or
something
fam she came back to the hotel room bent
over the bed
and said something alright outrageous i
remember i remember when he told me a
story i didn't even know what it was yet
looked like my dick twitched
when he said yeah says something like
said something like grab my hair
and like oh what did it say something
like smashed my [ __ ] back doors in
now
bent over the tape yeah you said yank my
hair and smash my [ __ ] back doors in
i said nah i'm tired
he just he just he said no went to sleep
i remember screaming at him that day oh
no one could say that to me
no just no this is his misses
it's just like [ __ ] when she walked
in when she stood in the doorway with
lingerie and he walked past the bedroom
and went straight past walked past her
went straight to bed
bro he was not interested in anything to
do with her but her money she used to
give him money on money on money
oh bless her disgraceful relationship
that's that's terrible so certain people
just use people that's terrible man like
i just don't understand how
a conversation hasn't been had yet
between them to you or at that time you
know i'm leaving you it's like
what are you doing you're not banging me
you're not paying me any attention and
i'm giving you money on top yeah so you
could i'm giving you money to so you can
spend on your habits that take you away
from me like what what where's the yin
to yank yes you know what am i gaining
out of this i don't know what these are
getting out of it what am i gaining out
of this [ __ ] relationship tell me
i'll be livid i'll be living james bro
yeah so this this yeah here she only
gets banged missionary
he doesn't eat he doesn't eat out and he
said her head is whack
i don't know if he i
i don't the yeah that sent this in was
clearly drunk because the grammar and
the spelling was all over the show okay
i think she might have said i think he
she was saying
when he does eat out it's dead ah okay
okay i don't think he's accused her of
having [ __ ] on top of him not even
doing it that's
that's too far
i was gonna say everyone has their
limits
that would be way too far [ __ ] hell
okay but um can you imagine you're head
of [ __ ] i'm not eating your [ __ ] but
just so you know your head is [ __ ]
um
that could never run wow so yeah he's
this guy is a user he's a user city boys
still got one back he's a user and
abuser
um but yeah man um and
she's now you're not also you have to
cut off you have to like your friend's
not listening to you yeah it's been two
decades you might have been friends
she's not listening to you yeah she's a
damn fool because she's gonna come
running back when
when he leaves her
should we she's ryan crying back to yeah
crying back he's gonna get bored of her
soon oh rags because he he doesn't even
want to smash her
he just he that's why he only [ __ ] you
missionary he doesn't want to smash you
yes it's done
what's the nut and he's probably
thinking about someone else closing his
eyes
just wants to knock can't wait to get
back to the telly oh i can't wait to get
back to the hotel a couple things lined
up i can't wait
let me just get this warm out this
warm-up nut out of my system oh my days
bless her yeah bless her
um what we got next we got um you got
some twitter stuff for me i got some
twitter stuff for you i do indeed so
um
what's it called i saw
someone tweet
let me see if i can find i need to find
the actual tweet itself
because it just it did bits to me mum
so the tweet was
who had the best
the tweet has been deleted takes
and as you can imagine wow as you can
imagine some of them okay some of them
are juice okay go go go go
imagine if men had to breastfeed babies
with their [ __ ] oh my god
this tweet has been deleted
jesus christ
this one is a tweet and a quote tweet
a naked iphone is beautiful but so risky
quote sweet
it's like a 15 year old
this is getting fam how much how how bad
are the rest
because the first thing you just said
when are they going to mellow out
[Laughter]
they're getting funny i'll probably ask
racing right now for what what have you
got left
this is a tweet and a quote tweet
see i gotta have the ugliest family
among celebrities i'll tell that to him
too
quote tweet his wife has got the jeans
of a neanderthal
have you seen his wife nah liberty she's
not good looking bro
i don't even know her name i'm just
going to type in ti's wife oh my god the
genes of a neanderthal
oh dear she's not good enough i bet i
have seen running around you've
definitely seen it before
i said she's not good looking
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
she knows how snooky
wow snooki
nah that's dressed
yeah
uh oh nah that's actually peak
i'm not even gonna read that one yeah
i'm literally not even gonna read that
one that's gonna get me in trouble
i knotted on the bus today and four
people turn around i felt like i was on
the voice
oh my god
oh my god's sake [ __ ] you know i've been
alive for 26 years and i've never seen a
chinese funeral on god they eat each
other oh my taste buff i'm not surprised
these lot got [ __ ] deleted fam
[ __ ] hell
my aunt pulled my my aunt pulled my
uncle out of his cancer treatment and
took him to a self-proclaimed student of
dr sebi's practices that [ __ ] lost 40
pounds in two weeks and died
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why was that one so funny oh my god
[Laughter]
why is that making me laugh so much
oh god
oh that's not good man
oh jesus christ that made me laugh
you don't [ __ ] about eight [ __ ] to
make me mad now look at you on
antibiotics
[Laughter]
hiding your man's toothbrush so we can't
talk to [ __ ] at work in the morning
some chick wrote this i want to start
watching sports but i don't know which
season to start does it matter if i go
in order
what
exactly what exactly she deleted it
you kiss a man's neck for .3 seconds and
he's already got oohs coming down his
leg have some self-control
[Laughter]
when i was younger yeah
if i was when i was a teenager yeah i
had
when i was a teenager bro yeah if i had
any and i mean any
physical interaction with a woman
my pre-cum was substantial
i can't even drink my drink
substantial
[ __ ] let me put this down my prenup was
doing
a madness bro and i used to be so
embarrassed
i used to like
i remember my first ever girlfriend she
was giving out hand jobs like there was
no tomorrow fam and every single time
bro pre-nut pre-nup
and i was freaking like that i used to
think she's gonna think you're my your
boy can't last seconds yeah
seconds yeah it used to [ __ ]
frustrate me you don't get it it's a
[ __ ] pissed me off
that's funny because that would have
been me when i was like 15.
some self-control
[Laughter]
that's hilarious [ __ ] oh god
ugh
you're scared of the vaccine but allow
white penis to enter your body
oh my god i lie
one of my followers be saying me and who
knowing damn well they're gonna die
alone
okay
ah the [ __ ] with no titties he's
cold-hearted how fitting
[ __ ] sake
therapy ain't enough i needed to kill my
dad
[ __ ] sake
when i was younger i used to measure my
dick mark it off on a ruler and stick
the ruler down my throat to see if
[ __ ] would be choking on it
[Laughter]
oh
stop to see if [ __ ] will be choking
on it
stop [ __ ]
oh my back's starting to hurt
so tweet quote tweet
someone tweeted gay son over thought
daughter quote tweet
you think your son not gonna be getting
his busty slighted out too
oh god oh my god oh [ __ ] laughing my ass
off in college my boys watched my drunk
ass break into this girl's house because
she told me at 11 to come get this [ __ ]
it was 4 00 am and i wanted what i was
owed
[Laughter]
wanted what i was owed nah
oh [ __ ]
i'm straining him i don't know if he i'm
straining my neck food
it's hurting
oh god i bet if i farted on that ant
he'll be like hiroshima for them man
i was owed
jesus
i'm only deep in what i actually said
man broke in the yard five hours later
nah
[ __ ] sake
oh man tweeted i'm bisexual bro i swear
sometimes i'd be mad sad then mad happy
idiot
oh god
quote tweet tweet and quote tweet again
grey's anatomy has been renewed for the
19th season on abc quote tweet somebody
needs to bomb that hospital
bro how has it got 19 seasons
how is that possible pam i used to watch
that show religiously i know you think i
stopped on like season 10. i stopped
around season 10. i can't remember where
i stopped but i i've not seen up to 19.
wait i i seen up to when i can't
remember bro
i think the last some of the last things
i remember is one brother running up in
there with a gun
shooting a couple of people
yeah yeah yeah um
the black doctor had a baby
broke up with a husband and son
a black doctor the woman what's her name
yang the chinese doctor
you heard me say black right i know you
heard me because you repeated it no no
no but you said
oh the black woman had a baby yeah when
he said black dog it reminded me of the
black guy that was dating dr yang that's
why i said yang
oh right oh the original guy original he
was a he was a boss he was a woman
smooth talking about his name but he
[ __ ] his hands up or something right i
can't remember what happened to him i
can't remember he lost it i remember he
fell off yeah i can't remember he said
he left him like season three or
something he left early to go to some
fancy dancy hospital yeah yeah yeah make
some real money
ah they got married him and yang in it
yeah no they were about she didn't do it
she didn't yeah he got to the altar and
she
she uh ran away is it because the mom
was chatting [ __ ] or something i
remember i can't remember gang used to
annoy me man i cannot remember oh god
anyway
my dick too small to be a rapist i'll be
thrusting and forcing myself inside a
woman and she'll be laughing i'll go
from rapist to a murderer
fam
this is
when you said like
the the deleted tweets thing i i
couldn't fathom
now some of them could be this bad
heinous
twitter is really scary it is bro they
say what they want
oh my god and man will get banned for
saying don't get a vaccine
and this is like
these aren't saying what i want
these hoes like white boys and they got
you're scared to say you're like
light-skinned women
that's
that's the truth that is the truth that
is actually the truth
oh there's a gang mentality
anything like that yeah yeah yeah
one guy tweeted homophobia got your
missing out on some good head
all jokes aside
i bet that's some of that that then
bathroom still slobs
then glory hole slops are better mad
i'm assuming they must be because i'm
assuming for girls if if another girl
gives another girl ahead they know what
they're doing
is so yeah my assumption is yeah i
reckon there's yeah those grinder slops
must be
because they're from strangers as well
it was just eager to please
strange they doesn't care what you look
like
imagine
bro no
that's i don't want to take it there
i don't want to take it there
but sometimes i think if i was a gay guy
and grinder yeah i would be doing the
most most
i'd be doing the most i remember
[Laughter]
i had a roller coaster of emotions one
time
do you remember the film shame
yes yes you talking about it on here a
few times
michael fassbender michael fassbender
and the scene where he's going through
it
there's a scene where he's lost he goes
for a jogger sign and he just leads him
down a dark path i think i remember and
he ends up in a gay bar okay yes i
actually do think i remember and then he
gets
sucked off by one one scary bald headed
guy and i remember he's walking around
the guy pins up up against the wall
and then michael
he tries to lips michael fassbender and
michael
interlocks his fingers and shoves his
head down
shoves his hand up
i remember watching it and i was scared
for my life
i didn't know what was going on i didn't
know if it was a fight
or what
next thing this guy is slopping michael
yeah and michael grabs the curtains with
both hands
he grabs a fist full occurrence
balancing his eyes are closed
and this guy's slopping and i'm thinking
oh [ __ ]
like
that is escalated
but the way he's gripping these curtains
that slops must be top
basically the slopping is topping
but i remember thinking michael get out
of there
but at the same time i was thinking
the way he's white knuckle in these
curtains
i don't know what's going on in there
because it makes you think have i
gripped curtains like that before that's
why i think i've never had a slot that
makes me white knuckles some shoes
the offset as well
oh
bruh
wild emotions
when i was watching that film
oh my god
oh that was funny [ __ ] thank you for
that that was funny
this one's sweet in me and i don't know
why but i'm gonna say it
michael jackson is lucky died in 2009
because of verses with the weeknd could
have gotten nasty
[Laughter]
that's stupid oh my god
oh
they're so dark the verses with the
weekend could have gotten nasty
[Music]
[ __ ] man
some man just tweet nonsense
nonsense
tweet and a quote tweet
there's nothing better than a woman of
prayer quote tweet he must hate never
had a freaky [ __ ]
a black person tweeted this a lot of
asian people look like laurence
fishburne
my eyes widened when i read that
because that doesn't make sense it
doesn't make any sense
oh my god
one guy wrote my blit
so raw and suckable right now
boy [ __ ]
raw and suckable
oh
stop now
oh my head's hurting me
oh i can't see that honestly
someone swears
they got rosa parks in hell standing up
i literally can't
that would be hell for her
that would be hell for her oh my god
i think that's it that's it all right
say less wow
wow fam some of them
had me up sent me some of them had me up
the self-control thing that's the
funniest one of all of them that had me
finished bro
honestly have some self-control it's
actually dreaded they don't understand
it's not about control i don't have a
choice it's not up to us
it's really not up to us oh have some
self-control so frustrating
oh god
oh [ __ ] man let me just breathe for a
second you say you got a recommendation
for me or something i'm not um yeah hang
on
oh jesus christ
so
i didn't know that this time would ever
come
but it's come okay
love on the spectrum
usa yeah it's i think i saw the trailer
not too long ago yeah maybe before i
went to sonogram bro
[ __ ] i accidentally deleted my notes i
had all the all the details in let me
get the cast i've i've been banging
through it did you just delete it just
now
yeah uh no not just now like half an
hour i was gonna say shake your phone it
will undo it
let's see if it does anything
oh i'm gonna have to go through the
whole thing
where there oh there it is yeah okay
right now on the spectrum usa
right so
they did two australian seasons i love
them
and i hadn't i had my favorites in there
pause sorry sorry we will get back to
you but did you ever finish married at
first sight
like finish finish
because you just said australian just
reminding me
did i finish it i think uh
maybe
i watched some of the final vows and
stuff
i'm not gonna lie to you if you had
i get this way sometimes
i love trash tv
but when the goss stops gossiping yeah
you just fall off i can't be bothered
yeah yeah yeah i hate trash tv but i
love when i get invested in the drama of
course and all this stuff but one it
when when
what they like to do is they like to
orchestrate drama after a while because
it's all dead and they like to try and
reinvigorate old arguments that just and
it all gets long that's when i fall off
oh okay the thing with trash tv my old
problem with trash tv is because
when i feel bad because when i talk
about on here i'm invested and i love it
all and all that stuff
but
i don't think people realize i don't
actually give a [ __ ] about the show
i don't care about whatever
whatever
whatever the sh the aim of the show is i
don't care you don't care about the
president i just want the drama and the
gossip yeah yeah yeah yeah i just want
the drama on the go i don't give a [ __ ]
about who ends up with who so the finale
is pointless but for me the finale's
pointless i like the reunions because i
want to see someone beef yeah yeah yeah
but yeah the the finale is irrelevant to
me i don't care who ends up with who i'm
intrigued a little bit because i can
invest in them but i really don't care
okay i just want the drama so when the
drama starts to die for a little bit i
just fall off it cool and i've got real
tv to watch fair enough okay bet but
yeah love it love inspection love on the
spectrum usa okay i've got my
fam
must say it now i think regardless of
what they do moving forward i don't
think i can sit through any more love on
the spectrum why it's breaking my
[ __ ] heart
every single time i watch it
i fall in love with these characters bro
and that i just can't handle it anymore
it gets the point i physically cannot
handle it anymore yeah
but it's just too much that sucks
it's literally too much bro i just can't
i can't deal with it yeah like so um who
have i got so they've got
they've got a few characters let me run
you through right
so they've got a guy called james right
so james is like in his 30s i think
he has like
it's dread because he makes me think
the way he acts
he acts like autumn yugioh mandom in
school
what do you mean do you remember those
like
dungeons and dragons don's okay okay
okay okay just like the
you know who i mean
the ultra nerds in school
and they used to just talk in riddles
um
he's just like them okay but extreme and
i think [ __ ] maybe their mom were
autistic okay not like i bullied him or
anything i just wasn't checking for him
okay um anyway
he is like
way into like
how to explain it like mythological
medieval kind of like stuff so he likes
dressing up in like cosplay and going to
like these like medieval fairs where
everyone's in character and all that
stuff and he just he lives for it but he
wants he wants love
but like he lives with his parents who
are like old as [ __ ] by the way and he
gets so embarrassed by his parents they
didn't give a [ __ ] they embarrassed the
shot of him and he's always like
oh
yeah oh you're annoying me um
i just want to find
a beautiful woman who uh shares my
interest in in this fam he's lovely and
like
he's just so straight to the point and
he always asks permission for everything
if he wants to compliment someone he'll
be like um
do you mind if i compliment your hair i
just want to say your hair looks really
lovely do you mind and then she'll be
like nast cool he'll be like your hair
is lovely oh blessed he's a lovely guy
he's a lovely guy that's him but he buys
into like all these old nights and like
these round tables and all this viking
[ __ ] he [ __ ] loves it he loves it he
wants to live in that world okay
so he's cool
there's another guy
called steve
talk to me talk to me who had yeah steve
is 63 years old okay 63 he's the oldest
spectrum brother i think we've ever had
on the show i said we've ever had
yeah and
he talks like
a he literally talks like a like a tv
host from the 60s
like a baseball like announcer okay he's
like all right then okay so he'll be
sitting there like my name is steve and
i'm
63
years old oh my goodness and he talks
like that but when i say he's a gentle
man it doesn't surprise me oh my god
that doesn't surprise me bro
the way he is with his friends
[ __ ]
yeah i couldn't have a friend like him
yeah i promise you now i couldn't have a
friend like him bro he'll meet his
friend for coffee he'll sit he'll be
sitting at a table his friend will like
come into the coffee shop and he'll be
like
oh wow
oh wow here he is
here he is i'm so happy to see you thank
you i've been so excited i'm so happy to
see you please grab a seat please grab
your seat tell me about yourself what's
going on
vam
he's so nice and uplifting to every
single person around him yeah yeah every
single person around him his friend came
in and they were sitting he was like oh
i heard you're looking for love and
stuff like that
and he was like yeah yeah yeah i am i am
and he's like uh so what are you looking
for in a woman he said honestly
basically the female version of you
so his boy was like
the way you make me feel after we spend
time together
wait this is my man telling stephen
steve is telling his best friend
this is what he's looking for oh wow
he's saying i want the female version of
you
the way you make me feel after our
interactions i'm uplifted for the whole
day wow you're so positive you're one of
the best friends i can ever ask for
you're always there for me if i could
find that in a woman i'd probably cry
tears of joy
he just said that off the bat wow
wow you had that's yours you could never
say that to me
you can never say that to me
because i'll sit there and cry i know
you i sit there and cry and say i don't
deserve you
i don't deserve you and neither does any
woman or anyone
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bro that's not odd
that's touching
that's touching bro
it's [ __ ] not on
and he goes on one day
that i've seen him so far he might go
more but like he oh he's chronically
lonely as well
when they say to him like ah
does he live by himself he's 16. he
lives by himself [ __ ] and um they say
like oh do you ever get lonely and he
was like oh
god yes
that's what he said oh
break my heart god yes
sometimes i get so lonely
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that will break my heart bro i said
oh
god yes
nah
bro i couldn't hear that in a public
setting
he says it's straight to the interview
guy oh my god oh god yes
i get so lonely
he said all i want is a woman that's all
i want oh i said if i could just have
that i'll be the happiest person in the
world yeah i get so lonely and it's
dread because he's so old yeah
he spent his whole life and for the
majority of his life people didn't even
know what autism was or understand it
the way we understand it today so his
whole life he just literally just got
told he was a [ __ ] weirdo yeah just
an outcast just an outcast he's never
ever had a girlfriend or anything people
just treat him like he's weird his whole
life
it's not [ __ ] on bro that's tough
it's really unbelievably tough like i
haven't finished it i want the best for
steve
i want the best for steve i want the
[ __ ] best for steve no one deserves
him
there's another indian brother on there
called sabode hilarious yeah he's
he's deep in the spectrum he's deep in
the spectrum explain that please bro
like he he's just social interactions
just on cutting it okay he couldn't even
talk he made it to five years old before
he could actually even talk oh wow yeah
but he's one of them genius autism
writers okay his maths is off the scale
like the guy was asking him like oh what
day was it
um on like the 13th of september 2006.
maybe like monday
jesus bro off the bat monday wednesday
there's a new black what's this times
this straight bang this he loves maths
oh wow bro they said like what are you
looking for and he was like oh love i
want to get married and then you're like
oh what like why do you want to get
married like because i want to go on a
honeymoon i want to go on a one-way
ticket around the world with the love of
my life
you know [ __ ] a boat
and his mom is dread because his mom
gets upset because she's
uh because they're indian she was from
an arranged marriage so this whole date
in ting she doesn't understand it she
doesn't know how it works so she
literally can't help him at all
he's gonna have to get the expert in to
help him out and um
he's so cutthroat
and he had a birthday party yeah they
expert all my man my master abode okay
so cut throat um his mom was doing a
speech but like i just want him to find
love and he's such a kind person and he
was like
i'm not he said at the top of his eye
i'm not dating an indian girl
i'm not dating an indian girl she's his
own party his own party to his mom
she was like it's fine that's fine
supposed the other day i'm not doing it
carry on say what you're saying i'm not
dating any new girl he just says what he
wants oh my god
that's
hilarious fab is [ __ ] funny that's
hilarious um but yeah he's he struggles
but he found a ting on his first date
yeah one down syndrome thing yeah
they hit it off like that okay they
think they have a lot in common they've
got [ __ ] all in common why do they think
they've got a long comment they found
like one thing in common yeah and they
could stick they stuck on that towards
the end of the day the whole day neither
of them do you like tv no do you like
youtube no do you like this no do you
like that no ease with a ping pong of
[ __ ] they don't like
they didn't have anything in common i
was thinking this is going terribly yeah
it's going [ __ ] terribly and then um
they found one thing common comment what
it was and then go back to interview
like how do you think the date's going
down syndrome was like oh my god yeah
it's going really really well
really really well
and then they go to him and he's just
like staring off into the distance
and they're like so what do you think is
going well he's like yeah it's great
it's going great i'm like
fam the deez man don't make eye contact
they just stare elsewhere
sometimes it's so jarring
[Laughter]
i love them but sometimes it's so
jarring the visual of that is sweet in
me
[ __ ]
some
bro
let me bring you on to my favorite
little love thing of the whole show so
far okay
danny and solomon okay oh my god anyone
watching this right now yeah
that's seeing the show is laughing when
i bring these man up
bro
daddy is son
danny's are [ __ ]
i'm gonna throw she doesn't know she is
danny's a [ __ ] cocktail
so
so
danny
um
right
so danny
is um young very pretty
and she works as an anime she has her
own animation business oh so she teaches
people on the spectrum to do animation
against animation she loves like anime
and just animation like comic con all
them things so she's always like i want
to find someone who's into animation the
way i am okay
so
she's probably passionate about it
and um she's like i really want love i
want this i want that she goes on a date
with this guy on the spectrum called
solomon
and solomon's way into like spirituality
and the law of attraction and all this
stuff right
so
so
they go on this date
and they're having a great time
and uh
she's
gassed off him
gassed off him she can't control it
and they're saying like uh giving your
other compliments on that if i'm there
talking talking she's like god i just
love you and he goes bam he said
right they've been knowing each other
like five minutes yeah yeah she's like
god i love you he said
what what did you say
and she was like i just love you like
i'm in love with you
man looked at the producer and said this
he said i need a break no
they were like you i told him he said
yeah i just need a break i just need a
break if i'm ripped off his mic and
walked off she was like [ __ ] i think i
scared him off
so he came back and he was giggling
solomon when i say hey
solomon giggles who had like t he he
does this he covers his mouth and says
he he no he doesn't he giggles doesn't
say he i promise you
he covers his mouth like this and when
he gets shy he's he'll say something
they'll be staring he'll make eye
contact and they'll go
it's the most hilarious [ __ ] and she's
like you're right he's like sorry i'm
just so nervous and he blinds it anyway
you're trying to put like cool guys uh
so anywhere as i was saying and they
make icons on time and he's like
giggles he can't help it that's too
funny
so
they're going back and forth they love
each other yeah and then
the the the date comes up these man now
lips in at the end of the day never seen
it on the left of the spectrum we've
never seen that before
lips in after the first day
down she goes back to her
her yard i'm sorry my nose is [ __ ]
itching me
oh god i don't know why my energy it's
cold cavity
um
so
she goes back like this guy is banging
this that this that this that i said i
lips them on the day and the mom says
bro oh she was about auntie i think you
need to chill she said to be fair i
think we should take it slow i don't
really know that much about him
second date he said to her auntie said
no she said that i don't really know
much about it okay okay
okay okay um
she rocks up to him
second date they go on this nice walk
they go to these like ruins like this
old castle
banging day he's gaster
saying you're my soul mate you're this
you're that she gets swindled in she's
trying to grill him and like understand
a bit more about him and stuff like that
so she's like you do work don't you do
have a job and he's like yeah i just
went back to my old job at ralph's
she said
ralph's
i said ralph's she's like all right
so
he said what about degrees
she said i'm sure he said you got a
degree he said yeah i just got this
degree i've actually just applied for my
second degree she's like oh swear sick
sick sick um to go and talking i just
think that we should spend this day like
not lips in um and just get to know each
other
yeah again again from they get talking
and get talking he grabs her face like
this
he grabs her face like this and lifts
her again she says you know we can take
it slow he airs her and lifts her again
if he had it's aggressive
it's [ __ ] wow aggressive is she
participating should she should be
heavily participating she's a bit heavy
she participates okay it was aggressive
i didn't like it i didn't like it
sam she gets back and then like how the
second day she was like it was good it
was good i'm not gonna lie i don't think
he's the man for me they're like rogue
one she's like i just don't think he's
got his life in order
she's like i've been running my own
business for years yeah i just don't
think he's at my level yeah
and she was like in the money was like
say so like do what you need to do
she's like i'm thinking i'm just gonna
i'm writing my letter on some she said
on some dear john [ __ ] i said don't you
dare she said text she's like now you
need to bail him yeah or meet him for
lunch or something let him down easy
she's like say less
she bails him on loudspeaker and i said
i've missed you this that this that she
said yeah yeah yeah i've missed you too
anyway
i don't think this is working he said
what
blind side
what what are you saying to me
she was like i just don't think you've
got your life in order because
and then he's like
big man what are you talking about yeah
and she's like yeah i just i want us to
be boys but i just don't think he said
bro
it did not go the way she wanted my man
has a break down
on the phone does he
a [ __ ] breakdown he's crying his eyes
out he's like you [ __ ] led me on you
led me on she's that big man i didn't
need john yes you did yes you did your
eye lips at me in the park telling me
this telling me you love me telling all
these things true fat true i
[Laughter]
i forgot about that swindling [ __ ]
she was running all the bars yeah man
said oh yeah i love you i just i'm just
in love with you man i had to take a
break his heart was overwhelmed he said
this
it was so jokes because i didn't know
that he just wanted to conjure get his
feelings together i thought he was
locking the whole thing i couldn't see
that as a producer
i would i would break down laughing she
said oh my god i just love you man look
straight in the thing they said solomon
you're right he said
i just need a break i need a break
it was the funniest thing i've seen time
he accused her of everything facts i
felt bad though because once she started
to hear it
she had one tear one tear just dropping
down her face
that [ __ ] here found that she had one
thug tear and at the end she was trying
to explain to the producers how she was
feeling yeah voice was
shaking
shaking and she was like
it had to be done it was just and then
it was dread because it made me feel
like a little kid like hearing a little
kid say this where she was like i just
don't like the fact that he sounded
upset and i've upset someone and avoids
shaking and then when she's trying to
say i've upset someone she's like
upset
and starts crying and she's trying to
hold together bro i just i needed to hug
her bless i needed darker and she was
like i just don't know i've upset
someone and then she went from she went
but in the world of business
we can't shed tears wipes the tears and
gets back to work ah
[ __ ] hell cut throat little [ __ ] tees
danny's sat and elves
wow said i'm in love with man and then
just said i just don't think he's got
his [ __ ] life together
wow he's not on my level bro
so fam i love love on the spectrum but
like i said i don't think i can stomach
any more seasons after this because i'm
tired of i've fallen in love with these
men and then seeing them heartbroken and
then it's just on to the next season
yeah
there's no rip there's no come up and
it's not going to double down there's
nothing nothing and i don't even
remember who found love in the last
season anymore
i don't think enough i think
i think homeboy
i'm pretty sure on the last one
my my ginger brethren who works at the
racetrack was in love with his down
syndrome thing
they hear off
apparently people are dancing love to
[ __ ]
fun fact
where did you hear that from i just
heard it somewhere
you just heard it somewhere i heard it
listen
matt said apparently people with down
syndrome love to [ __ ]
i just heard it somewhere
now
i can't
remember i'm trying to remember i heard
i think was on another podcast i heard
from a reliable source of someone who
used to work in care
that these down syndrome man just [ __ ]
that's what i heard
i
and i
based on
the last season yeah because i think i
told you the last season with my homeboy
who works at the racetrack and his
downstream during girlfriend she was
giving him [ __ ] me eyes i think i
remember oh yeah i think i remember oh
yeah she had the husky voice yeah oh boy
yeah so i wouldn't be surprised that's
hilarious um that was hilarious cool but
yeah that's love on the spec um i
actually do have a um trash news as well
oh going hit me i think you definitely
would have seen this this has been sent
around to god knows man
your ting
fought on a jar yeah
who the the thing that farts in jazz
fam when you said farner i thought i was
a name i thought you said mighting a job
i said
furniture i was thinking who james
[ __ ]
farna john
yes fight in a jar yeah yeah yeah i've
seen yes i have seen this one continue
so she's upgraded to boob sweat now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and something she's
making like seven bags a day something
crazy sucking crazy crazy
okay cool so
if you guys won't prove it to the
episode that we spoke about this before
it was a couple months ago now yeah
there's a girl she used to be a lover
i'm pretty sure she was at murray the
first sight us something like that
something like that she was
for those of you who weren't privy to
the episode that we spoke about before
there is um
a lady who was a contestant on
marietta first i usa i think i don't
know what season don't know much about
her who anyway she started a little
business selling farts in a jar
farmer
she started business selling farts in a
jar for cake to
these kinky man and she was making bags
from it but then she hospitalized
herself
because her diet was basically just
legumes facts yeah
and she just couldn't fart anymore
she literally couldn't fart anymore put
herself in hospital so she quit that but
then she's now got into selling boob
sweat in a probably in a jar again
probably and she's making bags from that
so
i'm glad that she's not farting anymore
but this ah
i don't want to be this guy
some people
really don't know how to manage business
like her for example she's terrible at
business
there's no longevity in what she's doing
fam
why can't she pick a niche that she can
just do why don't you just sell skitty
knickers or something like just because
you can buy them replace them buy them
wear them sell better wear sell buy wear
sell buy wear sell buy a website like
you can do this every day it doesn't
cause you any stress
why you gotta be out here just selling
titty sweat that's
you know how hard that is
it's all hard to collect the data
how were you fam just
sweating and then just yeah just
squeezing the titty it's just and why
specifically tit sweat
how how would a mandam even mentor no
exactly yeah there's no longevity well
there's no longevity in what she does
she just she's she creates terrible
business models but i guess a quick bang
for buck she gets a quick bag but then
she's she's putting herself out
she'll probably hospitalize herself from
dehydration soon probably she's probably
going to be doing like jogs in those
like you know those boxer suits
so you can sweat bare and then just pour
it into jars
and then just get paid but it's just
dumb like
there's literally no [ __ ] point just
do something now sell something that's
like not stressful facts just be a
normal like only fans go just do
something normal she's banging though
she's very good looking she's very good
looking but yeah she needs to chill with
all that but anyway best of luck um boob
girl bless her but that's fine guys we
are going to take a very quick break and
pay some bills yes
gentlemen
father's day
just missed it but it's not too late to
get your dad a little something belated
it's never too late and our friends at
mansgate are here to ensure all the
father figures out there are looking
daddy material this june guys facts
manscape performance package 4.0
which includes we're going to go for it
you already know the drill signature
lawnmower 4.0 fox it's the perfect
bundle to tackle any and all old man
hair from head to toe guys this right
here is no dad joke come on
treat him and yourself enjoy the four
million men your boys included worldwide
who dress manscaped with this exclusive
little exclusive offer 20 off free
shipping worldwide the code is sng so
you're november golf come on now
manscape.com
trust me his dad bod will thank you guys
thank you for listening straight back to
the episode let's have some more jokes
here we go
um
you had a show recommendation no yes i
do so i it's one i told you to watch as
well again
apple tv
they're not missing bro they're off the
party oh you said yeah you're not
missing so the after party
it's um
tiffany haddish she's um the main
actress and there's i think his name is
sam
off the poi camera's surname sam
something as well as uh it's got the
brother from ted lasso in it as well
hasn't it
said lasso yeah yeah yeah the black bear
in after party i'm sure it was the like
ghanaian billionaire in texas
set up bread up yeah yeah and it's also
got um dave franco james franco's
brother oh okay i like dave franco so
yeah those are the three main people in
the show right um
so it's it's a murder mystery series
tiffany haddish is a um detective
yeah she's a detective or like she's
like an understudy detective oh okay and
um dave franco has been killed in a in
an after party he's um he's like a
millionaire he's like a
in that world he's like a justin bieber
in that way interesting but
every episode
is everyone's different accounts of the
after party or the their day leading up
to that after party and their story and
it's like seven or eight characters and
you get to see how
where people are lying and like
how the different stories kind of makes
sense but also kind of don't because
tiffany haddish is the one listening to
everyone's stories okay separately in a
different way
so
every episode is a different person
and one of the one of the um episodes is
about her as well but each episode is
like eight or nine episodes maybe it's a
really good watch
it's a really really good watch the way
they've directed it written it and like
the way it's shot because it's only
basically shot in the yard well apart
from
like their backstories that are shot in
like elsewhere everything is based in
the yard and it's
really well written
really really well written so yeah i
would recommend people to watch the
after party okay it's a good show i'll
watch it i'm watching the boys at the
minute i need to jump on that james
you've never watched it never watch
season one or two i need to watch like
i'm hearing
i'm hearing this juicy oh
i'm hearing this juicy but i need to i'm
i've got two episodes left of stranger
things and then i'm going to jump on the
ball i haven't even started stranger
every episode is like an hour and 15
minutes [ __ ] hell yeah and the last
one is like an hour and a half too much
for me to watch i just finished ozark
just jumped on season three of the boys
once i finished seasons with the boys
but that's to be fast on a week week to
two weeks
um but yeah boys is amazing bro you have
to watch it okay um and then i'll watch
stranger things and then i'll watch
after party and then i'll probably watch
that other one that you told me mr
corman yeah yeah i need to bang for
yourself and then there's this anime
that i haven't been watching i haven't
johnson um bleach comes out at some
point this year uh that's this chainsaw
mounting oh [ __ ] i need to jump on that
one it drops
um there's a few things i'm pretty sure
shield hero season two is sweet in the
mix right now
um yeah yeah there's a lot there's a lot
going on there's just not enough time to
watch yeah yeah but i'm down man i i
love good shows same role alpha tv seems
to be doing the damn thing and they have
like
serious actors
serious yes yes bro
um what's his face um what captain
america was his real name
chris chris evans evans yeah he's got
our series on there called
protecting john or something something
like that i can't believe it's called
he's got a series on there i heard the
servant is good as well this uh oh i've
not seen it but i've seen it i think
it's got ron weasley in it or some [ __ ]
no it's um
it's um the sermon of essex or something
like that
maybe i'm thinking about it i'm thinking
of um you're thinking of the serpent
obviously yeah i'm thinking of loki
brother
the servant i'm thinking of him um is
like the main thing you know when you
log on to apple tv
it's like the flagship series
it's got yeah it's got ron in it and
it's got the other english spreader in
it
what's his name i don't know it's got
that guy with the beard that's in um
black mirror and some other stuff as
well okay in a film called rock and
roller i think as well okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah man i like those actors um
he's in my favorite episode of black
mirror
um what's your favorite black mirror the
one with um him in it where he they have
the
um the [ __ ] in their eyes that records
everything
and he catches his wife yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was an episode
that was an episode amazing episode
that yeah we've got bag of shows to
watch man bag of shows to watch oh yeah
his name was sam richardson and you were
samsung fair player um right questions
let's do ig questions yeah um so guys
as per usual you know the vibes
every week on instagram we ask you a
question of the week
and as per usu
the responses were interesting
right what was the question this week or
last week's question was um
what's the most embarrassing thing
you've been caught doing
right
okay right are they good good they're
good bro all right they're good they're
good they're good
i've not read them in ages because i
wrote them down this morning so i kind
of remember them
before you do it let me just piss quick
all right i'll be right back so yeah
take a sip of that water first
let's go hit me go what's the most
embarrassing thing you've been caught
doing i was on a date in a club and
walked into the mirror thinking it was
another room oh i've done that i've not
done that but i've seen a mirror in the
club thinking this place is massive bro
this place is massive
and then i start like i do wave and i
see myself like oh yeah that's me [ __ ]
were we in the same place where that
happened was it is there a place in mani
where that's happened before i don't
know gee in my avatar i feel i feel like
there was a bar that mean you went into
in manchester
and it was kind of like red lit and it
was long and thin
and i remember there was a mirror all on
the left-hand side i looked to my left
and i'm thinking this place is [ __ ]
huge is it that 186 spot that we went to
maybe maybe you're in that locked danish
period
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was there
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know that place
got burned on did i tell you no
it's not funny
it's really not funny new year's eve
brother new year's eve new year's day
day just gone this year someone burnt it
down someone like i say someone i think
um
something to do with like a sparkler or
something and some helium balloons the
thing ignited james oh i think it's all
[ __ ] i don't know now because i'm not
walked past it in a while but for months
it's not been open months did anyone die
not to my knowledge now far everyone's
ran out scattered out the place wow
wow yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
stealing drinks from weather spoons
someone got caught stealing drinks from
weather spoons
taking a [ __ ] inside a car tire and to
roll it down the hill
he's gone
how can you be embarrassed getting
caught doing that please yeah because
you should be embarrassed taking the
[ __ ] outside period
you're orchestrating some next level
[ __ ] this is literally yeah like how can
you be embarrassed if someone catches
you doing that because that's just
[ __ ] it's five years [ __ ]
i used to be caught daily having a wank
by my parents and sister
there's no self-control
there's no self-control there
i'm kicking them out of the house yeah
there's no
[ __ ] animal
get a [ __ ] out
every day
no no self-control
scratching my ass and sniffing my
fingers and in the corner of my eye i
see my grandma looking at me she put in
brackets i'm black by the way
[Laughter]
she would have got slaughtered
facts i could never ever ever get caught
scratching my ass
just
just a quick once over just to see what
i go on but man you look at someone's
deadpan staring at you
i'd buckle
i buckle and beg you don't please don't
tell anyone
please no i couldn't run bro he
physically couldn't run that's hilarious
practicing kissing my teddy bear when i
was 10 then i pretended to sleep when i
got caught
that's jokes
oh [ __ ]
my dad finding pics of me that i had
taken for my boyfriend whilst licking a
penis-shaped lollipop oh
[ __ ]
my dad caught me walking in heels and i
spent hours convincing him i'm not gay
[Laughter]
fainted whilst on a stand-up sunbed and
fell through the door salon naked
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
he caught me making balloon animals with
his condoms
yuck i just don't even know why like why
why
my mom caught me clapping cheeks she
went to the emergency room with high
blood pressure
i already know he was black bro rice
oh my god ah
my housemate caught me clenching a
vibrator in between my butt cheeks no
no
oh
fainted in church everyone gathered
around me trying to get the devil out of
me
my boyfriend was choking me whilst we
[ __ ] i blacked out and he said i
farted while i was passed out oh no
no
no bro no no no no no no there's nothing
more embarrassing than that there's
nothing more embarrassing
confession
okay okay go on
i remember
i was sleeping at a chick's yard right
and you know them deep sleeps
them deep not even not even deep sleeps
them ones where you're in limbo where
you're about to
enter the deepest news
yeah yeah yeah but any sudden tingle fam
i farted
but it was one of them ones where i
farted right but i was facing there and
she was here so i farted i was facing
this way
it woke me up but i didn't move james i
was like this i fight and i was like
i stood still for like 10 seconds
i opened my eyes and waited for about 10
seconds to see if she bunched or
anything to see if anything happened
i fired that just i remembered where i
was bro
that's happened to me but i've
it happened to me but i caught it after
the first clap
our mighty flew out my take vibrated cuz
i opened my eyes and i was i was like
please i just didn't move i froze james
i didn't breathe nothing i [ __ ]
frightened i was gonna say it but you
said it earlier i was gonna say i bet he
held your [ __ ] back i didn't breathe
i couldn't let her know i'm still active
da imagine bro imagine if you just
laid there like that and then all you
can hear say like
[ __ ] man nah
that would be so [ __ ] embarrassing
bro it was hilarious imagine she was
like now wake up
no what what you're [ __ ] batters bro
you just [ __ ] fight on me can you
smell that me i'll play deniability me
your nasty ass i was asleep i was asleep
i didn't fart fam yeah i was literally
with a thing one time as well
half asleep yeah in yeah in limbo and
literally it was that one
look
just that caught it woke up my ass was
clenched to pieces through head shaking
trembling bro lactic acid just building
in the cheeks i've never been so scared
in my life
was she asleep do you know yeah yeah but
the thing is
it could have been both ways like
we sorry we were literally asked to ask
like what you just said oh okay she was
facing the other way i was facing away
i farted my fart onto her so it could
have been a case where we both just woke
up
and just laid there in silence
still is the night
and then eventually i just drifted back
james when i said i didn't breathe
because
i [ __ ] froze man it woke me up
ah i couldn't have been a fly on the
wall for that bro i'd tell you that now
i could not have been a fly on the wall
i've never been so alert
that's too funny [ __ ] me jesus christ
anyway back to the agenda
yeah got my ears pierced when i was 15
and immediately faded in an isle of hair
brushes afterwards
oh my god telling the group chat how bad
he is in bed not realizing he was
reading everything oh stop that's a piss
take that means as soon as he busses nut
she was on the group chat in the bed
he didn't even leave the yard she'd even
wait for man to leave the yard
bro these don't give a [ __ ] she didn't
give a [ __ ]
bro they don't give a f
flying
fiddly [ __ ] it's annoying his dad walked
in on us whilst he was coming he kept
eye contact with me until his son was
finished
you know how scary that is that's not
embarrassing for her that's
traumatic that's assault that's a form
of assault
he kept eye contact with me
nah until his son finished nah nah nah
nah i'll sprint out there
i had a pic of my ex's id because i
couldn't remember his name for the first
three weeks
[ __ ] sake my friend my friend and i
caught someone give another man head
behind a mosque
behind the mosque
it makes it 10 times funnier in it i
don't know why i had to add it because
if it was a church i don't know why or
just it would have seemed a bit light
but behind
oh my god
it changes the game it changes
everything that's so funny
a man screamed a mask
it's just so much more heinous i don't
know why god
you screamed a mosque oh god that's so
funny that's hilarious
i'm doing the naughty on a balcony and
all i hear from the neighbor is bro she
said faster
[Music]
james can you imagine the embarrassment
no no no no
[Laughter]
bro she said faster
[ __ ] i'd go limp and walk straight back
in the yard
man is
literally spectating this thing
bro she said faster
nah brother oh she said faster
what are you doing fam no i'm here in
the same temple the same
don't make me come up and finish this
yeah off she said faster so clap it
faster oh my goodness well that's the
funniest one you said today that's the
funniest one you said today
faster
it's dread because like she's not even
when you get vex about that she's not on
your side because she did say faster
it's humor against you that means
literally it's hurting him against you
bro she said faster shut the [ __ ] up man
i did say faster i've been saying
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] ah you don't get how funny i find
that bro if i wasn't so tired i'd be
laughing even harder
oh that took my breath away
i'm glad this is faster oh right that's
too funny
i got caught trying to flatten someone's
tires oh
that was a scorned yeah i know it was
oh jesus
my brother walks in while i'm deep
throwing hairspray on skype i'm muslim
by the way
oh dear
fainted on my first photo shoot set
twice the ambulance had to be called oh
[ __ ] sake
the owner of the mansion where i was
working as a housekeeper caught me
tasting her food
[Laughter]
oh i couldn't the slave owner would have
come out fat the slave owner in her
would have come out for a belt
step forward hand on belt before she
composed herself
the slave owner and i would have come
out i already know it caught me tasting
her food oh
i
i as
as a house like as a homeowner yeah i
couldn't walk in and find my cleaner
just
picking that the mac and cheese will say
and just catching it with cheese
dripping down her lip
i i couldn't oh well i literally don't
know what i would do i don't know what
i'll do stunned james
stunned
because like
there's no point because my immediate
reaction will be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing yeah i know i can see clearly
what she's doing
why would you do that
that's the question why why are you
doing this not what are you doing
why are you doing this why are you doing
this oh my goodness
oh [ __ ]
and how long have you been doing this
clearly anytime i catch someone doing
something i refuse to believe it's the
first time
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh jesus caught me tasting her food oh
that's too funny
talking to myself with dramatics saying
the comebacks i should have said in a
fight ah
no one could catch me
having the arguments that i have
i promise you that who had
the imaginary arguments i have in the
shower
no
listen not a soul on this earth could
walk in on me and hear me having that
argument i feel exactly the same way
exactly the same way i've argued with
myself for the shower james i don't
think you get it bro oh i get it oh i
get it i play both roles with vigor with
vigor and uh it's it's weird because
i'm always the the winner out of it and
it doesn't make sense yeah yeah because
i play both roles yeah james duncan is
the winner but like my imaginary boss
comes at it
and i always have facts and i always
wiggle my way out of it and win the
argument james duncan's the winner
oh my goodness
shat myself during a football match and
then run down my leg like a madman so no
one could stop me
no
come on man
when i was 12 i fainted when my teacher
put a tampon in black currant squash in
sex education
yeah is that what they do on the go side
that's butters man
in blackcurrant squash
just use water i said i fainted
there's been bare faintness in this
sweet very faint sweet
when i was 14
i tried to [ __ ] my aunt while she was
sleeping my mum walked in with me on top
of her
i promise you now that shouldn't they
how how can i explain this
we know well i don't know
but
that's a person that wrote that
that's a real person yeah using their
real profile yeah well before i can't
remember if it's their real profile or
not but it's a profile it's a profile
yeah
so it's a person admitting into
attempted rape of a family member yeah
of a kin that's um what
that's nuts don't just confess stuff
like that for the for the bands that's
yeah that's nuts that's nuts that's nice
jesus [ __ ] christ
this chick said looking for money to
steal at my mum's friend's house
[Laughter]
the dj shouted you ready mid-set and i
was the only [ __ ] to scream yes
i imagine being the only one saying
at the top of your lungs imagine
not a single soul
in between your shoulder blades i would
smack it and keep my hand there all
right you [ __ ]
[ __ ] everything shoulder blades
fam i'd scream
the flash was accidentally on whilst i
was trying to take a picture of a girl's
bum when she was bent over
wow
[ __ ] my sneaky link caught me stalking
his new ting with a full government name
on google
imagine i could never imagine
imagine she is the sneaky link what's
your business
her full government name on google
google not ig not google oh shaker
i would shake her you're [ __ ] crazy
insane bro
google insane bro
oh that's so embarrassing if you had
this one you know
i say you know but
a lot of the times when i put these
questions up a lot of people write them
in like part part one part two part
three i air all of them because i can't
it's too much of a long story
i had to write this one down oh wow okay
sat at the computer with headphones in
hunched over like a perverted gargoyle
pulled on my dick like there's no
tomorrow whilst watching a japanese girl
get bukaked half to death
my dad tapped me on the shoulder oh
oh my god
why would he do that my dad tapped me on
the shoulder
that's
embarrassing
there's literally nothing worse than
that there is no embarrassment like that
it doesn't exist bro
embarrassment like that doesn't exist
why on earth would he tap him on the
shot let him just walk out
he tapped him on the shoulder i'm not
turning around
i'm not talking
if i got tapped while some edge up
stroking i promise you i had screamed
keyboard
monitor everything's getting dash on the
floor like dave chappelle and
when he's pretty when he's the president
oh yeah
i promise if i'm there hunched over and
i just feel a tap on my my immediate
reaction is i'm dashing everything on
the floor
oh my god
a japanese girl getting bokaked half to
death
oh my god i can't wow some embarrassment
like that
i'm leaving the yard i have to leave me
on i have to leave the yard bro i can't
i don't live here anymore [ __ ]
right caught my man wiping his arse with
one leg on the edge of the bathroom
everyone watched me drink my sister's
breast milk in the fridge and didn't
tell me they just laughed oh that's
disgusting
smashed an extra heavy set at the gym
then collapsed on the concrete floor it
was midday
my boyfriend caught me trying to twerk
in a back garden in my underwear
peak shame
peace shame trying as well not even
trying my co-worker found me checking
through his bag
the fear and lies don't come out of me
the fear and lies that will just spew
out of my mouth james
i would lie uncontrollably if i got
caught doing that
the things this is just making me
realize bro
the human population are so crazy
why on earth would you rummage through
someone's bag
why would you do that i don't think the
lies that would come out of my mouth oh
you've got no choice
you've got no choice bro [ __ ]
i've got a few more all right cool
i was caught leaving my necklace under
his pillow so i had an excuse to come
back
shameful alive
i was meeting my dealer and got into the
wrong car this old lady started
screaming
she must have thought this was our last
day on her fam 100
a strange young man just gets in your
car in the passenger seat
she was screaming oh 100
100
oh [ __ ]
i jumped on someone and called them a
[ __ ] thinking it was my friend
[Laughter]
was feeling myself trying to do a max
weight on the machine at the gym the
woman opposite me just started laughing
no she didn't
last but not least fainted on the church
faded on stage at church and told them
it was period pains and not the power of
prayer
but yeah man that wraps up the most
important thing
some of them
were torturous
bro that shoulder tap is is impossible
the rummaging through the co-workers bag
they're getting caught having an
argument with yourself i couldn't bear
i could i think i would vomit
there's certain things that are so
embarrassing that like
i'm i'm willing to move country over
this and bro she said faster then what
she said faster
wow that's embarrassing
fam oh wow
anyway guys i'm trying to think of what
my most embarrassing moment would be
oh good one good i don't know
um
mine
i've definitely embarrassed myself many
times
we're human but i'm trying to think if
anything comes to mind straight away
i don't think any i can't i've got bare
[ __ ] that's happened but i can't think
of anything specific
a lot randomly i've had a lot of moments
in my life that should have been like
the most embarrassing thing that could
ever happen but at the time like i just
wasn't embarrassed
like
i remember when i got steam and drunk
went back to a girl's yard and like
stopped mid bang to and i just puked on
her floor i think you've told me about
that and i puked on my clothes
oh yeah and i had to wear her dad's
pajamas home
that's pajamas so that is embarrassing
but at the time yeah at the time but i
didn't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i was
just like get me out of it mine was
in that same context where i wasn't
embarrassing the moment but it did seem
embarrassing
um the time my dad slapped me up and
down the shop
where i scattered the [ __ ] aisle
tell a lie the most embarrassing thing
that happened to happened to me was when
um
[ __ ] was when
ah
was when my in year seven when that
[ __ ] stole my bike
and then my mum got me in the car and
drove me around the entire neighborhood
grilling everyone my age
where did he live he stole my son's bike
oh yeah made me see in the past most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
[ __ ] i can imagine when we got to the
females bro that were in my year
oh my god
oh my god i couldn't i couldn't believe
it sorry g but yeah anyway
guys that was a good episode thank you
very much i think that might be one of
the longest ones we've ever done maybe
um anyway thank you for
for [ __ ] with us today guys
appreciate you always
and yeah man um
we'll see you on thursday the show yeah
we've got those coming first live show
on thursday so guys if you're coming see
you there um we're very much looking
forward to it it's going to be a great
time um as always guys as well if you
haven't got your tickets for our second
live show in september
make sure link is in the description
make sure you grab your ticket asap
we've only got a few left
uh if any by the time we're reading it
uh listen to this so
get on there get your tickets enjoy
yourself love love love
[Music]